hello and welcome for ya remote webcasts
this is chad hypo with the fda
television studio with me is katie
serrano of the city or h office of in
vitro diagnostics she's here to give a
presentation to you on FDA's framework
for regulatory oversight of lab
developed tests katie thank you so much
for allowing me to present remotely i'm
happy to be talking about this topic
which i've been thinking about for
several years now so the goals for my
presentation are to describe how FDA
regulates in vitro diagnostics generally
describe a little bit about our proposed
policy for regulatory oversight of
laboratory developed tests and discuss
next steps in developing LBG policy so
in vitro diagnostics as a class of
medical devices are a critical component
of clinical care and with some estimates
saying that they influence over eighty
percent of all clinical decision making
now I've Edie's were actually a bit
there under the 1976 Medical Device
Amendments they were defined to be
medical devices and therefore subject to
FDA regulation FDA is now charged with
ensuring that I VDS are safe and
effective so that they do what they say
they'll do for their intended use and so
that patients are not unnecessarily
harmed now the 1976 medical of I Device
Amendments did define in vitro
diagnostics and on this slide I've
actually included the very long
definition but essentially the
regulation defines that these devices
can be made up of test systems
instruments in vitro diagnostic kits
reagents used for laboratory testing
software algorithms as well as
calibrators and controls so as with
other medical devices the regulation of
IV DS is actually driven by risk and
risk in the context of an IV D and any
medical device is really focused on the
intended use or sort of a specific
statement made by the company about what
that test is intended to do so when we
define intended use we typically
describe a couple of things first of all
what the test is actually measuring or
detecting a general description of the
disease or condition that the
device will diagnose prevent cure or
mitigate the patient population
intending to be used that the device is
intended to be used on and the specific
type of specifying the specimen now a
single ivt could actually have multiple
intended uses in one example of this is
with HCG testing so the same test that
detects HCG and women could be used only
to detect pregnancy for example which
might be considered having a moderate
risk whereas that same test could be
used to screen for cancer which is a
much higher risk application of that
test and so in depending upon what the
use of the test is it could actually
have a different intended use with
different risk now for Ivy D's in
general when we talk about risk we're
talking about the consequence of a false
result and that as I said because of
that that factor the the same test could
actually have multiple risk classes so
IV deregulation and medical device
regulation breaks risk down into three
classes and devices down into three
classes class one representing the
lowest risk devices class to
representing moderate risk devices in
class three representing the highest
risk devices now only class 2 and class
3 products actually are required to come
in for premarket review class one
devices typically don't have any
premarket review requirements so just to
give you a general breakdown of how this
falls out in terms of how many IVD
devices fall into which risk
classification category about half of
them are considered to be class 1
devices that wouldn't actually require
any premarket review forty-two percent
or so is a typically class two and only
eight percent is class three so for the
class 2 and class 3 products that do
have the premarket review element what
we're looking for typically in our
premarket review is an insurance a
reasonable assurance of safety and
effectiveness safety meaning that
there's a reasonable assurance that the
probable benefits outweigh any probable
risks and effectiveness that there's a
reasonable insurance in the significant
portion of the target population that
that use of the device will provide
clinically significant results now for
both class 2 and class 3 products the
alum
ence of the premarket review package are
essentially the same in with respect to
analytical validity clinical validity
and labeling so analytical validity is
really making sure that the test can
correctly detect the analyte and here we
look for studies to be done that I that
can define the accuracy the precision
limits of detection and and other
information such as potential
interferences for information etc
clinical validity on the other hand is
really more about whether or not the
detection of that analyte identifies a
disease or condition and here we measure
that in terms of clinical sensitivity or
specificity as well as predictive values
now with clinical validity there we do
accept a wide range of elements that
could actually establish evidence for
clinical validity only in very rare
cases do we require prospective clinical
trials in most cases we accept
literature references or other
retrospective studies that have been
performed and then also our review would
include an evaluation of the product
labeling and really looking at the
claims that the manufacturer wants to
make about the analytical or clinical
validity of that test to make sure that
the studies that they've demonstrated in
their submission package reflect those
claims and again all of that assessment
is really focused on what the stated
intended use of that device is so how do
L DTS fit in with all of this well so to
start at the beginning LEDs are a subset
of in vitro diagnostics that are
intended for clinical use but are
designed manufactured and used all
within a single laboratory now I should
note that when a laboratory modifies a
device in a way that significantly
changes that devices intended use
performance or safety specifications
they would be considered device
remanufacturers and when this occurs
within a single clinical laboratory FDA
does consider these tests to be el DTS
now when these systems are intended for
clinical use either because they're a
new test that's been designed developed
and made within a single laboratory or a
modified test has been modified within a
single laboratory and
they are intended for clinical use they
do meet the definition of a device and
are therefore subject to after you
regulation however since 1976 FDA has
used a policy of what that we call
enforcement aggressive discretion for el
DTS so how this has worked out
practically is that while a traditional
manufacturer would actually develop
their test manufacture it they would be
required to go through FDA premarket
review and then offer that test through
a clinical certified clia-certified
laboratory an lvt since 1976 because of
this policy of enforcement discretion
could actually go ahead design
manufacture and use their test within
that clia-certified laboratory without
needing to go through FDA review now
this idea this policy of enforcement
discretion is interesting and I wanted
to make a few points about it first of
all the use of enforcement discretion
doesn't mean that the regulations don't
apply to that category of tests it just
means that FDA has chosen not to apply
them in that serkan in that set of
circumstances the use of enforcement
discretion is actually not unique to El
DTS we have used this on other products
for for other different reasons and many
of the reasons that F you might choose
to use the policy of enforcement
discretion are related to risk or other
factors that may play into a mitigation
of risks but that the the policy may
change if the risk profile and those
factors used to establish the policy of
enforcement discretion change now in the
case of LBT is a lot has changed since
1976 there's been an incredible
evolution in technology for testing a
lot of changes that have been made in
the marketing and business practices of
labs which really have increased the
risks associated with laboratory
developed tests and and we believe have
created gaps in LBG oversight now the
consequences in some case have have been
adverse health consequences for people
that have been using tests and making
clinical decisions based on incorrect
results in those cases there have been
unnecessary health care costs that were
associated with those incorrect clinical
decisions
and there's a lot of concern that that
problems in this area really could
undermine the progress of the
personalized medicine field which really
does depend on diagnostic tests that
work so this is sort of a visual
description of how this risk profile has
changed and you can see that early LD TS
had a lot of factors that really
mitigated the risks associated with them
and were part of the rationale for why
enforcement discretion made sense at
that time whereas many modern LD TS now
share risk characteristics that are very
similar to a traditional IBD kit that a
typical manufacturer might make and this
has really driven FDA to reevaluate
whether or not this policy of
enforcement discretion still makes sense
now over the years FDA has raised
concerns about this policy of
enforcement discretion and and and begun
to take action toward greater oversight
of these tests additionally there have
been a number of groups over the years
that have raised similar concerns and
that have identified FDA as the
appropriate agency to provide greater
oversight and I've listed a few of these
committees here including some of the
secretary's advisory committees and the
Institute of Medicine now more recently
FDA began sort of a public discussion of
how we might exercise greater
enforcement discretion for these tests
is starting in 2010 with a public
meeting where we really invited
stakeholders to start to engage with us
on this topic talking a little bit about
what this over greater oversight might
look like in some of the challenges
associated with it now this public
meeting in july july of 2010 was a very
widely attended eating we had over 600
people on campus and over 200
participating via web and we got a lot
of feedback at the meeting as well as in
the the follow-up period after the
meeting with public comment etc telling
us a lot about some of the concerns with
the laboratory tests themselves as well
as concerns about greater oversight of
in this area now because of a law that
was passed through the medulla
negotiations at fda is required to
notify Congress about any draft guidance
that is
created in this area and so actually in
July of 2014 we had taken all of the
comments from the 2010 meeting and were
actually able to notify Congress of our
intention to publish draft draft
guidance for outlining of greater
oversight of laboratory developed tests
that same guidance was then published in
October of 2014 now following the
publication of the draft guidances we
did hold another public workshop in jail
and January of this past year to engage
with stakeholders on the content of
those draft guidance documents to get
feedback from them about what they liked
about what they didn't like in
additional areas that we might need to
focus our efforts additionally after
those guidance documents published we
had a very extended comment period for
the document that was 120 days and it
actually closed in February and where we
received a lot of comments from
stakeholders about the document and then
finally in April of 2015 FDA and CMS
formed a task force on ldt quality
requirements and I'll talk about this a
little bit later in my slides so so I'll
transition here then to talk about the
content of the draft guidances that were
published in October of last year there
were two draft guidances that published
one the that outlined an overarching
policy the framework for regulatory
oversight Labrador lab developed tests
and then a second which was more focused
on on the details of implementation
which was FDA notification and medical
device reporting for laboratory
developed tests so in in the first more
broad-based policy document the the
goals of that document were really to
collect some basic information about LD
T's through a couple of different
pathways one being a notification
process which is a no-fee alternative to
registration and listing and the second
to being a collection of adverse event
reports or enforcement of the medical
device reporting requirements the second
goal was to try to use a public process
to sift through this information that
was that was obtained through those data
collection efforts to try to leverage
external X
Ortiz on actually classifying the risk
of laboratory developed tests that if he
had never seen before and then to help
us prioritize our enforcement efforts
for oversight and then the third goal
was to really try to phase in the
enforcement of premarket review over
about a nine-year period based on risk
and then finally to try to continue some
enforcement discretion for specific
categories of tests that FDA determined
to be in the best interest of Public
Health so I guess the one thing that the
guidance document did emphasize is that
there are certain categories of tests of
laboratory developed test that would
remain under enforcement discretion for
all regulatory requirements in those two
categories were I VDS only used for
forensic or law enforcement purposes and
certain LD TS for transplantation when
they're used in a clia-certified high
complexity histocompatibility laboratory
now for the first category of tests
there are existing controls in the
judicial system based on the rules of
evidence etc that provide a mitigation
for the risks associated with this test
and this is an existing policy and so
the the framework for laboratory
developed test is simply just not
interfering with that existing policy
for the second category of tests this
was recommended based on a secretary's
advisory committee that advised for
organ transplantation that advised that
that these specific tests have very
unique local local issues and the
because of the CLIA certification
process for these types of tests though
we thought the risks were mitigated to
have these remain under enforcement
discretion now the guidance walks
through the typical of requirements
regulatory requirements for medical
devices including in vitro diagnostic
tests and then discusses how those
requirements will be applied to a
laboratory developed tests and the first
is registration and listing requirements
now with the draft guidance document
describes is that it's FDA's intention
to continue to enforce our exercise
enforcement discretion for registration
and listing requirements as long as
laboratories notify the FDA of their
existing LD T's within six months of the
publication of final FDA guidance now
what the benefit of notification is is
its FDA will still be requesting
information of labs on their laboratory
developed tests but it's a no-fee
alternative to registration and listing
meaning that they don't have to actually
pay a fee to to complete this
notification process and also in the
2010 meeting we had heard a lot of
comments from stakeholders being very
concerned about implications of
registration and listing on on liability
issues for for their devices as well as
the need to pay the medical device tax
if they were registered in listed and so
we wanted to provide them with an
alternate pathways while they were not
in the active regulation face and so
that's why notification is so important
really the purpose on our end was to try
to collect some more information about
what what tests were being offered as
laboratory developed tests and what
their intended purposes were what their
intended uses were that could help
inform the external advisory panels in
their decision making of classifying the
risk of these tests and as well as
helping FDA and determine the priority
order that regulatory apply entire
mantilla plied so the the secondary
guidance that I had described that a
notification in MDR guidance describes
the types of elements that FDA would be
collecting through this notification
process a lot of it's very basic
information about the laboratory
themselves and the test but the other
elements are really trying to get at how
the test is used so that it can inform
that risk evaluation process that will
be used by the external advisory panels
now the next set of requirements that
are described by the the over the
framework policy are the medical device
reporting requirements which we people
more refer to as adverse event reporting
now what the current regulations say are
that serious injuries and deaths must be
reported and as well as malfunctions
that may lead to serious injury or death
must be reported to the fda within a
certain amount of time and we believe
that it's important to begin enforcing
these regulatory requirements on
laboratory developed tests to really
help provide a mechanism
or FDA as well as the labs to modify at
or significant adverse events so that
problems can be detected and corrected
in a timely manner and this would be
implemented within six months of
publication of the final guidance
document now couple things that I did
want to note about medical device
reporting requirements I think there are
a lot of misconceptions that
laboratories would need to somehow
actively look for issues associated with
their tests and that that might be
burdensome typically with adverse event
reporting this is it more of a passive
system so when a manufacturer or a lab
in this case receives a report or a call
or a complaint about their test they
would have to evaluate whether or not a
serious injury death or malfunction that
could have led to a serious injury or
death occurred and if so report it to
the FDA but they don't have to actively
go out looking for these these events
and then also FDA doesn't necessarily
follow up on every single individual MDR
that it's received and in fact most of
the time what we're looking for are
unusual events that might have occurred
with a particular device type or an
uptick in a type of event that we only
typically see occur occasionally and
even then really the first step fron
FDA's part tends to be more to reach out
to the company and try to understand
what's going on before any type of
action would be taken the next set of
requirements that are described in the
in the framework document are the
enforcement of premarket review and
quality system regulation requirements
now what we proposed in this area is to
phase in the two of these requirements
together so when premarket review is
enforced at that time only would quality
system regulate regulatory requirements
be enforced and there would be certain
categories of tests that would remain
under enforcement discretion for both of
these requirements those include class 1
devices class 1 devices typically don't
have premarket review they would be
typically subject to quality system
review requirements but in this case for
le cheese we are proposing that they
wouldn't be and the other three
categories of tests are el DTS for rare
diseases traditional LBT S&L DTS for
unmet needs and i'll describe those
three categories in the next few slides
so traditional LED
again these would be subject to
notification or registration and listing
and adverse event reporting but would
remain under enforcement discretion for
premarket review and quality system
requirements now traditional LD TS are
defined as tests that are designed
manufactured and used within a single
lab so they meet the definition of an LD
t they are performed by a lab on a
patient that is being treated within
either that facility or that facilities
health care system they use components
in instruments that are legally marketed
for clinical use so that means to say
they're not using research use only or
investigational use only components and
they are interpreted by quality
qualified laboratory professionals
without the use of automated
instrumentation or software for
interpretation and really the types of
tests that we meant to capture with this
category where things like cell culture
where for example the expertise of the
laboratory technician is very important
in making in using purchase media in
culturing the cells and then using a
regulated microscope to evaluate the
culture now the next category that would
remain under enforcement discretion for
premarket review and quality system
requirements rld TS for rare diseases
now again these tests have to meet the
definition of an LD t they have to be
designed manufactured and used within a
single lab and they also have to meet
the definition of a humanitarian use
device which spent essentially specifies
that less than 4,000 patients per year
would be tested using that test I think
one of the things that is confusing is
that even though this category is called
Le cheese for rare diseases really we're
talking more about rare rare testing for
example this would not apply to
screening testing newborn screening
testing because of the volume of
patients tested using those tests and
then the final category that remains
under enforcement discretion for
premarket review and quality system
requirements rld TS for unmet needs now
these again have to be true LD tease
they have to be designed manufactured
and used within a single lab there
should be no cleared or approved IVD
available for that specific intended use
and again they have to be performed by a
lab on a patient that's being either
diagnosed or treated in that same
healthcare facility or within that
healthcare facilities health care system
so i think the tricky factor in this
category is that there cannot be a clear
to approved ivd test available for that
specific intended use now once an fda
clears or approves something for that
specific intended use any cat or any
test that's on in this category for that
intended use would have a year to make
their own submission to the fda because
they would no longer qualify for this
category at that time so for the test
that do not fall into those categories
of continued enforcement discretion for
premarket review fda has proposed to
take a risk-based phased in approach
that will essentially bring these tests
in in a batch wise manner over
approximately nine years now the first
batch that would be called in for
premarket review are the tests that fall
into one of the following three
categories LD tease with the same
intended use is an approved or cleared
companion diagnostic lb tease with the
same intended use as a class 3 approved
class 3 medical device so those are
already considered to be the highest
risk class and there is something on the
market for that intended use and then
certain LD TS for determining the safety
or effectiveness of blood or blood
products now I should note that these
tests have one year to under the draft
guidance document to submit their their
package to the FDA but they would remain
under enforcement discretion that is to
say they could continue offering the
test to patients while they were under
review by the FDA now beyond those that
category in the first batch FDA will be
using that notification information to
with the external panels to help
classify tests into the risk categories
and then to help prioritize in those
risk categories who should be
prioritized for pre-enforcement
premarket review requirements now so
this sort of describes the timing of
that process so as I described there are
three categories that would be required
to submit their applications to the FDA
within one year
now for the tests that are identified as
high-risk by the panels that we that we
would be convening those would be called
in for premarket review between years
two and five of this phase-in period and
for moderate risk test those would be
called in between years five and nine of
that phase-in period now I wanted to
note a little bit of make a note about
investigational tests these tests are
used testa that are used investigational
II in clinical studies are subject to
the requirements outlined in 21 CFR 812
and just generally those regulatory
requirements depend on for
investigational tests depend on the risk
post to study subjects and that's
further defined in that regulation what
I wanted to emphasize is that nothing
about this framework actually changes
our current enforcement policy in this
area and that is to say that we don't
currently have enforcement discretion
for investigational devices and I wanted
to emphasize that point because there
has been some confusion I did want to go
through there are a lot of dates that
are outlined in the draft guidance
documents I think it gets a little
confusing so I think it's helpful to
sort of walk through that timeline
slightly so so first off they're at x 0
and x 0 here i'm defining as the time at
which the final guidance would publish
at that point any of ldt that wants to
enter the market in the the first batch
of tests that are up for premarket
review so those that have the same
intended uses a clear to approve
companion diagnostic those that have the
same intended use as an approved class 3
medical device or the LBT s4 blood or
blood products those actually could not
come on to the market without premarket
review for new tests trying to enter the
market at six months all L DTS that are
subject to notification and adverse
event reporting would have to complete
that that process at one year the the
tests and that how those highest risk
categories would be submitting their pre
market submissions to FDA and beginning
to comply with qos reg requirements at
that time between years 1 and 2 as I
mentioned we would be completing this
public process to get input on
classification for El DTS and for
are prioritizing the the risk of how we
would call those devices in in the
phase-in period a guidance document
would publish at two years that would
outline that process and announce the
priority list for remaining high-risk LD
TS at three year three that would be the
the second group as identified by the
the panels that the next group that
would be called in for premarket review
and between years three and five the
remaining high-risk tests would be
called in for premarket review now here
for we would publish another priority
list only for moderate risk tests
outlining how they would come in to the
FDA for premarket review during years
five through nine and then they would
actually submit their applications to
the FDA for review during years five
through nine so today we're actually not
even on this on this timeline we're
actually over here somewhere because all
of these timelines are driven by when
the final guidance document publishes
and as you know what we've published so
far has only been draft guidance which
is not yet implemented so as I mentioned
we had a very extended comment period we
had the the public meeting following the
publication of the draft guidance
documents and I did want to talk a
little bit about some of the public
feedback that we have gotten on the
documents at this time so first we've
heard from a lot of labs that they they
want more time particularly with certain
requirements such as notification
adverse event reporting and quality
system regulation compliance they also
noted some concern about whether that
first group of tests that would be
required to submit at one year would
actually have enough time to do so they
also noted the need for more clarity and
certainty in some areas so for example
they had really noted that they wanted
more certainty as to when they would
need to come in so that me of
emphasizing the FDA should hurry that
classification and priorities
prioritization process as soon as
possible so that they can better plan
for what would be happening to their
specific tests they noted a need for a
little bit more detail on modifications
and which modifications which would
actually create a new lvg that would
therefore be subject to this framework
they asked for a
little more information at four how a
lab compliant with Korea regulations
could also become compliant with Q s reg
and trying to understand a little bit
more about what current activities that
are that are performed by laboratories
could be leveraged toward this effort
and which q s reg requirements may not
be applicable to them at all they also
noted the significant need for FDA
outreach and education in this area
obviously this is a brand new area for
laboratories and and that there would
need to be a lot more engagement with
the laboratory community to help them
through this process and potentially
even doing things like educational
inspections instead of having typical
FDA inspections at first that we also
got a lot of comments on the categories
for continued enforcement discretion for
premarket review and that these should
be modified slightly so for traditional
LD TS there was there were a lot of
comments that those tests should be
under complete enforcement discretion so
meaning no notification or adverse event
reporting because they were so manual
and so driven by the expertise of
elaborate Orion additionally we heard
that laboratories for unmet needs that
there was a lot of concern that labs
wouldn't know when an FDA had after you
had cleared or approved a test and so
therefore their test didn't actually
qualify in that category anymore and
that uncertainty was unsettling for a
lot of labs and then also that health
care system factor so that factor for
both traditional ldt S&L dt's friend
Matt needs that the lab performing the
test had to be doing so on a patient
that was being treated within their
healthcare system there were a lot of
concerns raised that that would cause
problems with patient access to
important tests that wouldn't be
desirable and then finally there were
comments that that there needed to be
additional carve outs for continued
enforcement discretion for premarket
review for other categories of tests
such as those that are only used for for
surveillance purposes so in terms of
next steps FDA will be has been
reviewing and synthesizing all of those
public comments that were received
through the public meeting and through
the comment period and we use those
comments to really modify the guidance
Bay
son that public input received one of
the things that we are planning to do
that is not typically done for a
guidance document is to provide a robust
response to the comments that we
received to explain where those comments
were incorporated into our documents and
why maybe some of the comments were not
were not incorporated again that isn't
something we typically do for guidance
however we want to be as transparent in
this process as possible and and we want
to provide that to patients there to
laboratory so that they better
understand our decision-making and then
finally we're moving through the
administrative process for these
guidance documents currently and we
intend to issue final guidance in 2016
and of course really taking to heart the
the call by the laboratory community to
provide ongoing education and training
that is definitely in the works on fda
side I should note that we do have an
email for el deeb for questions about
the LBT framework it's the ldt framework
at eight the fda HHS gov and we have
dedicated staff to to answer questions
as promptly as possible now another
thing I wanted to mention was that in
April of 2015 FDA and CMS actually
joined together and formed a task force
to really try to clarify and coordinate
the roles of CMS and FDA with respect to
L et quality there had been a lot of
concern by the lab community that these
regulations might actually be
duplicative and it might be burdensome
for laboratories to comply with both and
we really wanted to address that issue
head-on together so a couple of things I
wanted to say about this this task force
so number 1 fda a CMS have had a
long-standing relationship and we really
do understand the important role of
accrediting organizations and the role
they play in the implementation of the
CLIA program we as part of the task
force we actually did invite all of the
AOS to discuss their requirements for
laboratories and how those requirements
relate to l BTS specifically as a team
we reviewed the the intersection of the
FDA and clear regulations and then as
part of that analysis we learned that
the
regulations don't specify how a lab
should meet requirements that be it
which leaves room for labs to implement
processes that meet their own unique
business and operational needs finally
FDA and clear regulations what the task
force was able to determine was that
they are not in conflict that they there
aren't activities that are required by
Clea that would put a laboratory in
violation of the FDA QSR reg or vice
versa so I think that's good news for
laboratories there's nothing that will
will create issues for you with those
two regulations sets so with that I'll
open of this presentation up to
questions I do want to highlight that
additional questions can be asked
directly to me through my email or to
the LBT framework it's you'll get a
faster response if you send them to the
ldt framework okay with that I have some
questions that have been submitted and I
understand from your presentation Katie
that the comment period is now closed
for the draft guidance is there still a
way that folks can still provide
feedback to the FDA on those draft
guidance documents there absolutely is
and I would say the best way to submit
that information is to actually send it
to the LBT framework items or to the
framework mailbox we do review those we
incorporate them we're going through the
administration administrative process so
essentially the the guidance writing is
done except that as we move through this
process we incorporate additional
feedback so there is still an
opportunity for that to get included and
also we're drafting additional education
and outreach activities you know
materials for that that those those
questions may be incorporated into as
well okay and you'd mention in there
sometime in 2016 for the publication of
the final guidance you really can't nail
it down any more accurate than that wish
we could it's a it's a sort of a magical
process and and we don't have a you know
a way to give any more detail than that
but I can say that we are moving through
the administrative process and that is
our good thing is you're still taking
feedback even though officially the
draft guidance has closed you're still
taking the feedback to incorporating the
final guidance so it's it's not like
you're ignoring everything
coming up no absolutely not we want to
hear from you all right now some
laboratories have claimed that LD tease
our services and not devices and
therefore FDA does not really have
authority to regulate the lab develop
tests what is the official policy on
that sure so you know at the beginning
of my talk I talked a little bit about
what makes up an IV d device and and
whether you know those components that
are part of the ivd device so as you can
see whether those the definition of a
medical device actually doesn't specify
where that those components are going to
be put together so whether they're put
together by a traditional manufacturer
and sent out as a kid or whether a
laboratory puts them together and offers
it in their own laboratory they are
still medical devices subject to the 22
the medical device regulations okay and
has the FDA approved or cleared any
tests that would fit the definition of
the lab develop test you actually have
we've had a couple of laboratories that
have chosen to come into the FDA even
despite our policy of enforcement
discretion they felt that it was
important for them and where they were
headed with that test to have FDA
oversight and so they actually did
submit their we've had a couple of PMA's
and we've had a 510 K as well and that
process really has helped both sides
learn a little bit about each other okay
now there's labda the tests that are
offered directly to consumers things
that you can buy it rite aid or
walgreens or whatever take the test and
send it in are those considered lab
developed tests and why or why not yeah
we have actually not applied our policy
of enforcement discretion to direct to
consumer tests and really it's been
because since there isn't a medical
intermediary there are a lot of concerns
that the risks associated with a patient
making an inappropriate decision based
on that test without having that
external FDA review to help validate the
the claims made by that test it's too
risky and so we haven't actually applied
our policy of enforcement discretion on
those tests okay I have another question
here I want to I want to read it just
right to make sure that I don't don't
get this backwards now they they say
here I'm a laboratory that doesn't make
any brand new lab developed tests but I
do modify existing test kits to accept
additional sample types that may not be
listed in the pack
it's insert now is this considered a lab
developed test yes I think that's a
great question and certainly this is
something that a lot of labs do but when
you change the sample type that really
can change the performance
characteristics and so that would
actually be a change that significantly
changes the intended use and performance
of the device and would actually can
make you make your lab re manufacture
and and therefore subject to the LBG
framework as described ok now will this
policy proposed policy for lab developed
tests discourage labs and companies from
developing new tests or will encourage
them to make more tests right certainly
this was this idea of us getting in the
way of innovation with something that
weighed heavily as we drafted the draft
framework guidance and as we move
forward toward the final certainly we
don't want to get in the way of
innovation and really one of the big
drivers for creating the categories for
continued enforcement discretion for
premarket review was driven with that in
mind so we have tried to look at areas
where innovation has really been
important and certainly in the area of
rare diseases we don't want to you know
to stop innovation in that area and then
also where there's not essentially no
other option for laboratories available
we wanted to to allow for innovation
there and so that ldt for unmet needs
category is very important okay and with
this new draft guidance has CMS weighed
in on the guidance and do you know how I
that'll affect CMS's operation
administration of their Clea programs
and other programs that they have
absolutely so we have been working with
CMS since well before the 2010 public
meeting but that relationship was even
more formalized this this past year in
April of 2015 they're very much on board
with what FDA is doing and and through
the work that the task force is done we
really have confirmed that there aren't
any issues with FDA oversight impacting
the clear program at all okay good so if
a lab is developing tests that they want
to submit information on for their tests
now do they have to wait until the
guidance is issued or can they or the
guidance is finalized where can they
submit it now no they can sit in it now
as I said we have had a few companies
that have chosen to come into the FDA
and
engage with us I think they found that
that our interactions have been
beneficial and have actually improved
their product if a company isn't ready
to formally make a premarket submission
we do have a process called the
pre-submission process where they can
engage with us as they complete their
validation studies to help them
understand whether or not they're going
to be acceptable once they do submit
that premarket submission or if they
have any developmental questions they
can put them to us through that formal
process as well you know our office has
been very interactive with folks I think
that's something that's very important
to us we we want to be as open as
possible and we want to help people you
know develop the best test possible for
patients actually well thank you very
much for your time Katie that's all that
I have for questions so thank you very
much it was a great presentation and now
back to you folks at your at your
meeting wonderful thank you
you